مع اقتراب موسم الحج يبدا المصريون في
تدبير نفقات الرحله التي تاتي هذا العام
بكلفه عاليه جدا بسبب تراجع سعر العمله
المحليه وازمه توفر العملات الاجنبيه واقع
دفع عددا من المصارف لطرح برامج لتمويل
الحج عبر قروض تسدد على اقساطهم بفوائد
ثابته برنامج التقسيط لحد 12 شهر وممكن
وفقا لطلب العميل ان انا اكستاند المده
وفقا لاحتياجاته فمن المتوقع وهو ده
الحقيقه شايفينه حاليا
ارتفاع التكاليف هتؤدي الى اوه هي ادت
فعلا لزياده الطلب على برامج الحج والعمره
بعض المصارف وضعت 16 الف دولار كحد اقصى
للتمويل واخرى لم تضع حدودا قصوى بينما
وصل سعر الفائده الى 17% عدا المصروفات
الاداريه ورغم الاراء المعارضه من رجل
الشارع الا ان هذه البرامج تجد من يقبل
عليها قرض ده بيعتبر ربا
وما ينفعش اطلع بفلوس ربا معاك تقدر تحج
اهلا وسهلا ما فيش خلاص استنى لما يبقى
معاك ربنا يقدرك وتحج ما فيش السنه دي
يبقى السنه الجايه ان شاء الله غدا خدت
القرض ده ورحت عملت عمره ولا عملت حجه
وتوفتي هناك يبقى عليا فلوس ورغم ان بعض
رجال الدين اجازوا الحاجه بقرض حسن الا ان
اخرين رفضوا وبشكل قاطع الاقتراده لاداء
الفريضه فما دمت انني لا املك القدره
الماليه لا يجوز لي شرعا ان
احج بمال بفائده لا يجوز شرعا لان هذا
المال في هذه الحاله قولا واحدا عندي فهو
مال حرام لانه دخل في شبهه الربا ان لم
يكن ربا في اي
تحفظ من اي عميل طبعا احنا بنقعد معه
وبنشرح له الموضوع بالكامل وبنوري له
الفتاوي الفتاوى الشرعيه اللي موجوده
عندنا عندنا كمان هوت لاين للرد على اي
استفسار لاي عميل فيما الجانب الشرعي فده
برضو بيساعد العميل جدا ان هو ياخد القرار
ويقدر يشوف الواقع بنفسه في ظل اجازه كبار
علماء الازهر اللي موجودين في الهيئه
الشرعيه لمصرف المتحده لتلك البرامج بعض
المصارف تقدم مباراه تامين على الحياه
لصالح البنك لضمان سداد القرض في حاله
وفاه الحاج المقترض قبل السداد تامر نصرت
العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات